at least one culprit of the infamous iby
power match fixing Scandal has been
unbanned I truly thought I would never
get to say those
[Music]
words okay so before we get into it
friendly reminder to all of the
Counter-Strike fans out there that we
The Score Sports have a face it clan
play with me your friends and the rest
of our community collect face it points
and buy cool things like skins in the
shop it's totally free to join just
click the link in the description below
so yeah steel one of the most respected
and long-standing igls in the history of
North American Counterstrike will be
able to compete in valve sanctioned
events as of 20125 we know this because
he tweeted it on the 10year anniversary
of the extremely notorious match fixing
Scandal of which he and his teammates
were apart Steel's ban will be no more
now if you know steel from valerin
there's a fairly real chance that you
don't know the story behind any of this
back in 2014 seal played for a scrappy
North American CS go roster called iby
power in a sio match against net code
guides they threw intentionally for some
skins he's going to have two right there
can they line up for him what is he
doing why did he hesitate so much
doesn't matter has the CZ gets one gets
taken down now it sounds simple and in a
sense it is but it went on to become one
of the biggest scandals in the history
of Esports we made an entire video
detailing the origins severity and
longevity of the Scandal which you
should check out if you want to learn
more but it suffices to say that it
might actually be Global offensives
greatest controversy you see after the
match fixing came to light valve the
makers of Counter Strike published a
blog post where they issued indefinite
bans to each and every member of the iby
power roster save scadoodle who
apparently chose not to share in the
spoiler the careers of bra dazed azk and
seal were all but ended not only did
valve bring down the banhammer but they
made it fairly clear over time that they
had no intention of lifting it the years
went by and even as tournament
organizers began lifting these guys
bands to non- major events they were
never really able to ascend past tier
two and three rosters how could they if
every time a major came along they'd
have to bow out but Steel in particular
worked really hard to make amends
instead of sulking or simply staying
quiet he created content that would help
casual players he continued competing in
lower tiers and even shot the occasional
PSA match fixing damages the competitive
Integrity of the game and can be fatal
to the ecosystem and if you get caught
you can face severe consequences B you
can be permanently banned from Majors
that means you have to work shitty tier
3 events as a Caster is match fixing
wrong yes is it cheating yes should it
be punished severely yes but let's be
reasonable the reality is that these
guys made like ,000 each off of their
poll and faced an ostensibly permanent
ban for a crime that has plagued Esports
since the days of brood war and whose
culprits to this day mostly go
unpunished I'm not making excuses I'm
simply saying that if forsaken can eat a
fiveyear ban for using actual aim hacks
on land then surely we can let a guy who
has spent a literal decade trying to
make amends for illicitly copying a sick
knife or whatever off a csgo lounge
learn from his mistakes and that's
exactly what valve did last week steal
tweeted out of nowhere that come January
2025 valve would be lifting his band to
say that a significant portion of the
community collectively rejoiced would be
an understatement what's really
interesting though is that he didn't say
anything about the other members of the
ibat power Squad whether that's because
he doesn't know didn't feel that it was
his news to share or because he's the
only one who got unbanned remains to be
seen A lot of people are wondering
whether this means bra could come back
but as of right now we simply don't know
he has understandably been putting his
all into valerant over the past couple
of years and while I don't think that
that should be the determining Factor it
could be that valve simply think that he
and the other guys haven't earned it the
reality is that any such lifts are long
over do and it's not even really
apparent that the players can do
anything with them anymore I'm not being
critical or harsh I just 2015 was a very
long time ago the game has changed a lot
since then as have the players still in
the case of Steel the lift is deserved
even if it's just for posterity's sake
the good that steel has done for
Counter-Strike has long outweighed the
bad and it would have been kind of
disrespectful to the Counter-Strike
scene at large for valve to have
continued ignoring that plus who knows
maybe he'll re-inject some real life
back into nacs maybe he won't but he's
one of the figureheads of the scene and
we need all of the help we can get
either way it was the right call Legacy
is important and steel deserved for his
reputation to be redeemed this was one
of the dumbest darkest mishaps in the
history of Global Offensive it would be
very cool and very cathartic I think for
all of their stories to come full circle
hopefully they do valve just arbitrarily
one time decided to issue permanent bans
to one single roster for one crime now
they have done it since like other
people who match fixed for larger
amounts of money I don't know yeah it's
it's these guys did 10 years Danny 10
years dude